alors oui on a les moyens notre système
de soins et moi je tourne la question
autrement c est ce que notre système de
soins a encore les moyens de l'austérité
et des crises du capitalisme
voilà un petit peu un petit peu l'enjeu
est la première chose à faire peut-être
ces deux des maths dédramatiser l'enjeu
l'enjeu du trou de la sécu l'enjeu du
déficit de la sécu parce que toutes ces
questions en fait l anesthésie le débat
parce que voilà les mots les chiffres
sont en ordre de bataille vous rendez
bien pauvre vous rendez bien compte il
ya des déficits avec des chiffres qu'on
est même pas capable de ce2 de se
matérialiser et évidemment tout de suite
on se dit ah bah il faut bien il faut
bien pour la sauver pratique et la
saignée non il faut dédramatiser il faut
se dire que dès le début la sécurité
sociale est contestée sur sur sa
capacité à être à l'équilibré que on
place le début en 1945 ou bien avant les
gouvernements dont vous avez parlé la
sécurité sociale et l'organisation
collective de la santé en france a
toujours été critiquée sur différents
modes pour dire que ça coûtait trop cher
que ça inciter à la feignantise à
inciter à la consommation non justifiée
de soins bien tout ça on en fait on
n'est pas du tout capable de le
démontrer et au contraire comme vous
l'avez dit l'un au grand problème
aujourd'hui c'est le problème de l'accès
aux soins avec beaucoup de gens qu'ils
renoncent à accéder à des soins la
pandémie a montré avec éclat que notre
problème ce n'était pas un problème
d'argent quand il a fallu mettre
l'argent pour assurer un accès aux soins
à tous pour enfin donner des moyens aux
hôpitaux et pas encore suffisamment mais
on a pu le faire et toutes ces questions
qui avait anesthésié le débat public
pendant des années la dette le déficit
et cetera etc elles se sont plus posés
momentanément aujourd'hui elle se repose
pourquoi non pas parce qu'elles sont
devenues réelles d'un point de vue
monétaire budgétaire mais elle se repose
parce qu'il ya un agenda politique qui
est de remettre en cause la sécurité
sociale alors qu'au contraire il
faudrait l'étendre notamment avec le
projet durant deux siècles
[Musique]